what else you get up to in the UK you
were there for a while I saw right yeah
no I don't know what I did I did a
church and a prison that was fun I got
oh [ __ ] that's so [ __ ]
it was literally [ __ ] it was awful oh
this is not fair yeah well why is it not
fair wait I remember I had a much better
time than I did so I don't want to hear
it I remember I got I disappointed uh an
old man though I made him lose his faith
in the Youth of today what a drone
incident remember what do you remember
oh yeah so you know Chris wants to get
these drone shots so we're getting these
drone shots in this uh and this country
field near the church area yeah and um
yeah so we're just driving and then
Chris wants to get his drone back so we
pull up into this like really dirt road
opposite someone's house yeah the
drone's coming down and if you if you
know anything about like rural UK people
are very nosy right like when something
happens near their land yeah they tend
tend to be like you know on the ball
especially older people yeah because
it's like they know everything that
happens yeah yeah they do not missing
and I I thought oh my god when Chris is
pulling out the Dr putting the Drone
down outside someone's out of house I
was like oh they're gonna come out I
know they're gonna come out so the Drone
comes down into the thing and I grab it
and put it in the car and as you're
coming out this older gentleman comes
down and basically like Flags us down
right so Chris you know had two choices
stop or just go off yeah so Chris
decided to stop gentlemen yeah yeah so
then
um the the guy you know he's like is
that your drone that just went into that
field and Christopher's like you could
see the decision in Chris's head of like
do I lie do I tell the truth I lied so
he lies he said no it wasn't my drone I
don't know and he's like oh because you
know like he went in that field and uh
you know I hope that something hasn't
happened to her yeah and then Chris is
like oh I lied yet what's my drone
[Laughter]
I lied it was my
the guy looked so disappointed the guy
like it was like his son had just told
him he'd laugh that's the exact way you
admit to your parents as well you know
like like sorry Mama did lie I did do it
okay then well it's really awkward and
really just a Christian it was just like
two awkward people talking to each other
I'm just sitting there crying in the
corner laughing while they're just like
well then yes
by the way there's a beautiful view up
here it was just like that's cringing it
was like out of here I thought he would
be like why are you flying a drone I I
don't know what people in the UK think
of drones yeah it's my first time and I
was like [ __ ] is he gonna report me to
the police or something yeah
I don't know why I then went I was my
drone I lied I should have reworded that
like oh that drone yeah that was mine
because the two or two children that
would have felt like less like awkward
well I said like I don't know why I
literally said oh sorry
and so then Chris felt bad immediately
and then back pedaled which yeah in the
worst way his faith in the Youth of
today
I'm not talking to someone you could
tell that guy wasn't out for blood you
know because some people come out and
the you know the first thing they say is
they've got to jump on their shoulder
yeah they're just ready to fight whoever
did that yeah he didn't seem like that
yeah but you know Chris likes it's like
and now he's gonna be that kind of guy
now that guy's not gonna trust people
yeah the moral of the story of this
episode of trash taste never lying yeah
don't lie guys don't yeah so you know
people ask me that like did you actually
have a five-star hotel book I did that
night and then Chris dragged me to this
[ __ ] Church
it's awful that's fun on it so everyone
that comes like whoa a church but
obviously being raised in like the UK
yeah you see churches all the time so we
I was like I don't I want to stay in a
church by being a kid again I hated
going to church as a kid I basically I'd
run out of ideas right on this trip to
the UK I need to do a video because I
had nothing planned I was like a wacky
weekend and because it was the Queen's
Jubilee everything good was literally
sold out or take it right yeah yeah so I
don't know how we found it but there was
a church and I was like that'll do [ __ ]
it let's go there and [ __ ] it [ __ ] it it
was awful but the there was a really
good Pub next to it I'm really really
nice actually but it was really I mean I
I don't believe in ghost but it was
quite unsettling staying in a church I
wake up at 3am and you're just in this
Pulpit of a church and you just hear
like creaking and like
I was they provided there's a hot water
bottle to fill up and I was like well
I'm using it Chris thought I was like
dumb he's like making fun of me being
like hot water while it's hot today and
I was like right we'll see at night and
then in the morning he wakes up like
shivering going I should have used the
hood and I was like yeah you should have
it was a really weird two-day because it
did that and then we stayed in this
prison yeah I saw you guys stayed in the
prison couldn't convince me to do the
person I was like no not doing the
president I thought it was going to be a
lot more pleasant than it actually was
it turned out halfway through the toilet
someone had like killed themselves in
our cell they'd like put a rape around
there yeah he was like he was he was
telling like a ghost story you know
about like a prisoner that had gone
insane and he was like by the way who's
still saying in cell number nine and
we're like
uh that's one of the most active cells
yeah it's like that's one of the most
active cells a guy hanged himself there
and I'm like good I remember thank you
waking up in the middle of the night I'm
always trying to wake up at 3am when I
stay somewhere haunted a weird yeah woke
up and Joey's on the floor like
I don't know how I feel and I was
looking at the window thinking oh my God
this is really unpleasant in a cell and
I and I thought when I booked this stay
in the prison night experience In
fairness it was the cheapest wacky
weekend I've ever shot because the
church was 100 quids the prison was 100
quid yeah so good cheap accommodation if
you want to stay for cheap in the UK yes
stay in a literal prison I thought
there'd be like a bed in the prison cell
there was no bed there was expecting
like a five-star five-star hotel yeah
ghosts
I thought there would be something
I can understand if they were offering
to stay in a prison that they might have
like something to be honestly we had
this lattice metal thing that you put a
mattress son yeah that was it and then
the floor it looked like a cheese grater
did you bring like a sleeping bag or
something yeah like the thinnest [ __ ]
Amazon basic sleeping we were using the
one that I used the night before
probably yeah because I think the the
champagne as it's called Church camping
oh originally I think the booking
initially had a bed in it right but then
they removed it because of covet yes and
then they were like you have to bring
your receiving bags now it was like what
it's like could you imagine a normal
Hotel yeah
you have to bring your own to the hotel
the mattress is soaked and covered it's
just like what I I didn't really get it
it was it was just uncomfortable the
church it wasn't very fast yeah it was
just cold and [ __ ] also cringy yeah also
Chris and I had this weird thing on the
drive to uh the prison where we just
like found a bunch of really weird named
English towns I don't even loving it
because Joey's before this you've been
the UK once or twice before once and we
never we talked about about the UK [ __ ]
mate there's a lot nothing there because
Connor gave him a tour of like Croydon
and that was it because I was like I'm
gonna give Joey the best tour and a
prison cell yeah take your match with
Australian Roots but I'd only ever I'd
only ever been in like London for a few
days yeah and that's my whole experience
the prison was in a really nice place
near him bath right yeah we're driving
there and Joe's just look at his friend
like Nutley and all these like weird
obscure names like crap crap crap
Stratton on the force and he's like man
this is so funny it might be like a
[ __ ] stupid name it's ridiculous look
at Australian Town names and laugh this
is how I feel yeah Joey Joe had a whale
of a time yeah and I was like we have to
go to kravnell yeah so we actually took
a detour nothing incredible 7 A.M after
this prison drove to crap now it's just
a farm that was literally crap and it
was just well that's why it's called
crap surely right awful but yeah that's
the UK in it yeah yeah to be fair though
it was like once we were actually out of
London and you know in the National
Countryside it was very very nice the UK
is good yeah I really enjoyed it what do
you think Stonehenge
it's there almost underwhelming place
because there's people ruined it for us
you used to be able to go upstairs yeah
I wish I would yeah I feel like it would
have been local if I were is it one of
like the seven world wonders or
something like that this might be yeah
yeah what the [ __ ] is wonderful about it
that's pretty expensive like it is it's
not wondrous at all isn't it wondrous
because they're wondering how the [ __ ]
they made it because they have no idea
how they made it or where they got the
stones from or something right uh I
don't know how they carry the stones
yeah how they would have been able to
place the stones like that thousands of
years ago yeah all I know is it was more
expensive than that Michelin star
restaurant to go and look at it you get
to the door and it's like five thousand
five it's like five thousand yen each
yeah
that's very cheap the one Hokkaido was
better you're up to it yeah yeah I
wanted to buy a little like knick-knack
for Rocky on like a little Stonehenge
thing because I'm like that because you
know we collect knickknacks from all
over the world and I was just like it's
like 70 quid for [ __ ] knick-knack of
Stonehenge I'm like no that's stupid who
the [ __ ] is
anything different about the UK though
when you were there
um honestly I thought there was I don't
know maybe it's just where I was living
but there was definitely like a lot more
food options I thought like the food
option and just the reindeer the food
quality in general in the UK was just
like a lot better oh God yeah everyone
like clowns on like UK Cuisine you know
yeah yeah rightly so in some senses but
in this on this trip back most of the
restaurants I went to were actually like
yeah they're really good really bad I
mean most people mocking the UK
foolished Americans who've never left
America so you know or Japanese like
Japanese people and British food really
annoys me they're like oh your food very
bad I'm like have you been they're like
no I'm like [ __ ] go there eat the
fish and chips eat the shepherd's pie
devour them covering like go and enjoy
it and then like rank it and rate it
like yeah I find British food is really
good particularly pub food there's a
reason I put on four kilograms in the
three weeks
oh bro I just go to town yeah the UK is
good but I did reach a point the first
two weeks I was like why would anyone
not want to live here it's amazing it's
magical yeah things weighed me down like
you know things going wrong I remember
things don't work in the UK yeah
like an Airbnb and then the shower just
didn't work oh I don't have you been in
the UK yeah I've had so many Horrors
Airbnb and hotels hotels in the UK watch
hotels are pretty good in the UK they
are you're not even paying like an
exclusion anymore you don't even get a
[ __ ] toothbrush
I thought that was weird no that's the
same all over the world it's just Japan
and a few other countries immunity wise
because they most countries I go to
America Thailand I'm pretty sure most
American hotels don't give you
toothbrushes really think about when we
were when we were in America at the
hotel we stayed and didn't give us a
toothbrush Australia gave us two
Australia
basically every like every country is a
knot don't give toothbrushes because
it's bad for the environment to just
give a disposable toothbrush every time
it's a lot of plastic yeah true and also
like a lot of hotels I think reuse soap
not like in the traditional they like
take it and then mash it all down okay
right right which is good I I understand
like okay I I love the convenience of
the toothbrush at the hotel but I get it
that it it is just a waste like you can
just bring your own because you're
bringing your own medicine or uh why did
you spill it you just spill it on your
eye
like do you really need a toothbrush at
the hotel because you're probably
bringing a bag of amenities anyway right
yes I do most of the time because if if
like England had more convenience stores
like Japan I wouldn't mind as much do
you bring your own amenities I forget
all the time
that's because I bring them now because
I'm just used to it the thing is most
hotels that don't Supply toothbrushes if
you call up the front desk
forgot mine they'll be like yes yeah in
like in like more expensive ones but
it's I don't know it's like travelodges
dude
yeah but like it's [ __ ] Windows size
yeah no no what I'm saying is like Save
the Planet yeah I know come on listen we
don't need the [ __ ] toothbrushes we
just bring your own in there the hotel
in Australia had the wooden toothbrushes
yeah exactly so did uh yeah exactly yeah
[ __ ] I the one thing pissed me off at
Japan right let's say I just want more
toothpaste than your supply I have to go
and get more toothbrushes because they
only Supply them in a um right so you
get toothbrush and toothpaste so I
wanted I had brought my own toothbrush
but I I wanted toothpaste so I had to
get like three toothbrushes and just bin
three toothbrushes to get the toothpaste
I wanted which felt really bad because
I'm like great I just threw a three
perfectly good toothbrushes because they
didn't give me the option why would you
not just go to a continuity just get
some toothpaste I feel like the trash
takes toothbrush let's see there's a new
plushie let's make some money I think
the the final straw in my time like in
the UK was just one of my last days just
one of the ATMs I use every day I just
watched I just piss on it at night and I
was just like what is this like [ __ ]
happened
yeah I was just like oh don't really use
your cashmere I barely used cash no it's
like an advertising campaign against you
genuinely after I mean I I don't I don't
I I didn't use any cash in the UK or
America it's just a top now yeah it's so
good so it's so convenient a thousand
pounds drain from your account instantly
yeah oh my God it's amazing well
certainly not be using cash on that ATM
anymore but it's like people just
respecting the just the public space I
kind of I Like the Way in Japan people
are really good about taking care of
their surroundings yeah yeah yeah we
don't in the UK I think that's a real
problem well a lot of countries don't do
that I think it's Japan is the weird one
in that sense
this much about taking care of this
space things just work it's very
convenient